conclusiones la economía no está tan mal
como se estaba esperando hace un par de
meses hay optimismo generalizado sobre
que no va a haber una recesión segundo
que seguimos en un periodo de poli
crisis Este es un término que ha sido
acuñado a lo largo de este foro
económico mundial para describir tanto
la alta inflación como el alto
endeudamiento y los consecuencias del
cambio climático adicionalmente Pues a
las tasas de intereses posible que sigan
subiendo a lo largo de este año para
seguir controlando la inflación Por qué
Porque la inflación no ha llegado al
objetivo si bien si se está
desacelerando no llega el objetivo una
inflación saludable es de entre el 2 y
el 3% y está en hasta el 10% en Europa
el 7% en Estados Unidos
cuarto que se está perdiendo la batalla
definitivamente contra el cambio
climático pero están intentando Buscar
soluciones si me permite voy a citar dos
frases que me parecieron interesantes
una de cristalina George va la directora
gerente del fondo monetario
internacional quien dice que esto sí es
una guerra mundial Por qué Porque acabó
con toda prosperidad del planeta y la de
Cristina la presidenta del Banco Central
europeo que dice que china emprendió un
cambio de política que puede que mate a
muchos pero que salva la economía
refiriéndose a la flexibilización de las
medidas que emprendió China para
salvar su economía y reabrir Su economía
después del covid